cuba si castro nos c'est le slogan une
soirée solidarité avec le peuple cubain
qui se tient en ce moment même au
théâtre du rond point à paris à
l'initiative de reporters sans
frontières
les organisateurs entendent dénoncer la
répression castriste
de nombreuses stars ont répondu présent
jean et ses rangs olic et y est
l'an dernier you elle était encore
journaliste à cuba quand il publie par
internet un article sur le trafic des
appartements propriétés de l'état
alors la police s'en prend à sa famille
you elle doit fuir
il vient d'obtenir le droit d'asile en
france un coup à simplemnt à cuba c'est
très simple et si tu lis tout ce qui
n'est pas publié par la presse
officielle est interdite montée c'était
un motif de persécution par la police
politique
en mars dernier le président communiste
cubain fidel castro fait condamner le
poète raul rivero et 80 journalistes
indépendants à des peines de 14 à 28 ans
de prison
cuba oui castro non le thème de la
soirée organisée par reporters sans
frontières
la fille de raul rivero raconte le
procès truqués de son père si on lit la
sentence jusqu'au bout on voit que le
crime de raul c'est d'être journaliste
sinistre échos d'un autre procès en 1989
plusieurs militaires fusillé pour trafic
de drogue la fille de l'un d'eux le
colonel de la guardia veut également
rétablir la vérité
mon père était militaire et il ya eu il
y avait une prise de conscience et
c'était une pelisse et conscience je
pense qu'elle fait en france n'est pas
la télé strict et c'est ça qui a coûté
la vie à mon père ou cuba oui castro non
pour mobiliser l'opinion
reporters sans frontières fait appel à
des stars sophie marceau lite un poème
de raul rivero je n'ai rien contre ceux
qui m'ont rendu la vie impossible mon
unique il faut vrie passagère la plein
de gens qui savent pas exactement ce qui
se passe à cuba d'une part et d'autre
part mobilisé je dirais cette gauche
intellectuelle qui depuis 40 ans
trouve des excuses un dictateur qui
s'appelle castro au pardon monsieur le
premier ministre je ne vous avais pas
vus merci des mois qu'il faut regarder
les choses telles qu'elles sont cas ce
qu est un dictateur
les pratiques tateurs de droite ou
gauche les indicateurs le cigare les
longs discours
aujourd'hui le communisme tropicale sert
tout romantisme et le mythe cubain
s'effondre devant les atteintes de plus
en plus nombreuses aux droits de l'homme